did you see this is a clip going around
from the Iowa caucus it's an insane clip
of a woman who's already like cast her
vote and she's finding out Pete Budaj
is gay after she voted for him
take a look how come this has never come
out before it's been in the news for a
year yeah it's part of the news for a
year and she didn't know that people to
judge is gay now it's shocking for a lot
of reasons this primary is important and
you'd think voters wouldn't have known
more about the candidates they're voting
for even worse
check this out this was not an isolated
incident take a look at this raw footage
we got from another district in the Iowa
caucus and who are you Kaka Singh for
today yeah I cast my vote for Warren Oh
Elizabeth Warren why are you going for
her maybe I'll Lizabeth her no no no
one's a man named Elizabeth Warren is a
woman well what am I just now finding
out about this I went with Bernie 100%
you're not at all concerned that he's 78
years old wait for his old and then I
hear that I guess I'll go with Biden
Biden in 77 but I've seen him kissing so
many young girls so what are your
thoughts in the caucus to be honest I
just want a decent white male presidents
like Obama was
[Music]
for both times wait am i black look I'm
just proud to be a voter in this great
state of Wisconsin sir we're in Iowa
yeah right why does it have Wisconsin on
my driver's license this is a Costco
card holy [ __ ] honey we got a Costco
card wait it's Costco gay
good question the fair question is
Costco gay